Not even Scarlett Johansson in a skin-tight
bodysuit could stop the bad reviews haunting
the 2017 live-action remake of Ghost in the
Shell.
While the film should should serve as a reminder
that adapting anime for the silver screen
isn't as straightforward as one would think,
studios are still determined to keep trying.
A number of U.S. studios have anime adaptations
in production right now, so strap on your
cat ears, pop open some Pocky, and check out
these anime properties that have upcoming
live-action remakes.
Death Note
Based on the manga series of the same name,
the original animated adaptation of Death
Note won an award for Best TV Anime in 2007.
A decade later, there are high hopes for the
American remake.
Adam Wingard, director of the horror-thriller
The Guest, has said that he's enjoyed the
freedom that comes with releasing his live-action
version of Death Note through Netflix, suggesting
that their lack of a rating system means he's
been able to incorporate all the madness of
the original.
The film, which is due to debut in August
2017, stars Nat Wolff as Light Turner, with
Willem Dafoe providing the voice of his demon
companion Ryuk.
Which, honestly, isn't too far off.
​Alita: Battle Angel
Produced by James Cameron, Alita: Battle Angel
is an adaptation of a '90s cyberpunk classic.
The Terminator director was first introduced
to the manga series by Hellboy and Pacific
Rim director Guillermo del Toro — who, knowing
Cameron's body of work, thought he'd be interested
in it.
Laeta Kalogridis was brought on board to pen
the script, and her personal knowledge of
the property helped bring the remake to life.
Directed by Robert Rodriguez and on course
for a July 2018 release, Alita: Battle Angel
stars Maze Runner's Rosa Salazar as Alita,
a cyborg who's been recovered from a scrap
heap by a cybernetics professor played by
Christoph Waltz.
Michelle Rodriguez and Jennifer Connelly round
out the supporting cast.
​Akira
The Hollywood adaptation of Katsuhiro Otomo's
Akira has been in development hell for so
long that it's almost become a thing of legend.
But recent stirrings about the hunt for a
new director have raised eyebrows again.
News of a remake first broke in 2002, but
a mixture of script, casting and budget issues
set it back over the next decade, and it seemed
to have finally been called off in 2012, with
Warner Bros axing it as part of studio cutbacks.
Rumors that the studio was finally ready to
take things forward with Akira began popping
up again in 2016 when Justin Lin was set to
direct, though more recent rumors place Jordan
Peele at the top of WB's wishlist.
So, has Akira been rescued from development
hell?
TIme will tell.
Tiger and Bunny
Originally a one-shot published in 2011, Tiger
and Bunny went on to be serialized as a manga
and then adapted into an anime series — all
within the space of a year.
Producer/director Ron Howard was first attached
to a live-action version in late 2015, when
it was announced that his Imagine Entertainment
would join forces with Bandai Namco Pictures.
The story takes place in Stern Bild City,
where people known as NEXTs have started developing
superpowers.
Given Hollywood's obsession with superhero
properties, Tiger and Bunny could potentially
do big things, but Howard and Namco know that's
a delicate job.
Screenwriter Ellen Shanman was given the task,
who Howard called the "perfect match to adapt
this wildly popular story for new audiences."
​Fullmetal Alchemist
Unlike many upcoming anime adaptations, Warner
Bros.' Fullmetal Alchemist live-action remake
is being shot with a Japanese cast, using
Japanese language — which is a little unusual,
considering the story's set in the fictional
country of Amestris, which is loosely based
on 19th century Europe.
Director Fumihiko Sori explained,
"I want to create a style that follows the
original manga as much as possible.
The cast is entirely Japanese, but the cultural
background is Europe.
However, it's a style that doesn't represent
a specific race or country.
There will never be a scene in which a character
says something that would identify him/her
as Japanese."
Japanese fans are reportedly fearing the worst
for Fullmetal Alchemist, which was rated the
second-best anime of all time on My Anime
List.
The film is due out in December 2017, and
based on what's been revealed so far, it'll
closely follow the plot of the original manga.
​Voltron
Despite Netflix beating Hollywood to the punch
in 2016 with their critically acclaimed, animated
reboot series Voltron: Legendary Defender,
a live-action feature-length remake of the
classic '80s show is still being developed.
Voltron was the brainchild of the late Peter
Keefe, who licensed the giant-robot-based
Japanese shows "Beast King Go-Lion" and "Armored
Fleet Dairugger XV."
Keefe's team spliced them together into a
brand new show with overdubbed English dialogue,
creating new stories in the process.
DreamWorks acquired the rights to a live-action
Voltron film years ago, but when Universal
bought out the studio toward the end of 2016,
the project ended up in temporary limbo.
More recently, Universal announced that they
still intended to make Voltron, with David
Hayter of X-Men and Watchmen fame on board
to pen the screenplay.
Still no word on who'll form the head, though.
​Robotech
Another US anime made from existing Japanese
shows, Robotech combines Macross, Southern
Cross and Mospeada into a brand new universe
for American audiences.
Director James Wan is a fan, and his knowledge
of the series' origins should serve him well
in the adaptation's creation.
The film suffered a setback when rights holders
Harmony Gold disagreed with how Warner Bros.
were handling the property and decided to
shack up with Sony instead.
There are no official production dates or
cast to announce yet, but we do know Sony
ordered a page one rewrite of the script.
So, how close will this skew to the original?
Harmony Gold's Animation president Tommy Yune
said that we should expect something new,
saying,
"It's a clean slate.
It may share commonality in that it is based
on the original series, however, the writers
are taking a different approach to it."
Attack on Titan
The beautifully brutal manga Attack on Titan
had a whopping 66 million copies in circulation
as of April 2017, and that will only rise
if Warner Bros. can bring their planned live-action
English language adaptation to the big screen.
The story takes place in a world where humanity
lives in a huge walled-off city, which is
their last defense against the Titans, grotesque,
man-eating giants.
Attack on Titan has already been adapted into
a two-part movie in Japan, and not completely
successfully.
Despite the earlier adaptation's setbacks,
Warner Bros. intends to remake these two films
rather than adapt their own version directly
from the original manga.
Deadline reports that Warner Bros is locked
in negotiations over the remake rights, with
Harry Potter producer David Heyman lined up
to take charge of the project.
If the studio fails to strike a deal, others
will soon be lining up to make their own pitch
and a Hollywood remake of Attack on Titan
seems like merely a matter of time.
Naruto
In 2016, respected manga magazine Shonen Jump
revealed that a Hollywood remake of Naruto
was in the works under the guidance of Lionsgate
Studios and director Michael Gracey.
In terms of source material, the original
Naruto series consisted of 220 episodes, and
Naruto: Shippuden aired a whopping 500 installments,
so the filmmakers certainly won't run short
on ideas should this film develop into a franchise.
And considering who's producing, Marvel Studios
co-founder and former chief executive Avi
Arad, that's a very real possibility.
If anyone knows how to transition from print
to the screen, it's him.
Wary of superhero fatigue among audiences,
he went looking for a new angle.
According to his son and partner Ari, they're
working on creating an "incredibly visual
and cool world."
Hopefully the two will have learned some valuable
lessons after what happened with that other
big anime movie they produced, 2017's Ghost
in the Shell...
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!